[Applause]
we should do a night where everybody is
from their home you know we get the
whole band
great just all different tv sets that'd
be cool we can't afford it
uh we got no money here
true um you know folks uh as of course
it is that time of year it's the
holidays and uh you know it's it's just
crazy but it seems like every time you
turn on
tv like you know in the last couple days
uh you see something that's christmas
related
all the tv shows have a christmas theme
christmas commercials everything's got a
you got a christmas theme
well last night i turned on the
discovery channel because i'm a bit of a
science buff i thought i just want to
watch a science show
even they've gotten into the christmas
act their show was about christmas last
night
the discovery channel showed a piece
about santa claus and where he came from
and it was fascinating was eye-opening
to me in case you missed it
here's a sample
santa claus throughout modern history
this overgrown elf with the heart of
gold has been the subject of christmas
lord the world over
first catalogued in 278 a.d in the
plague ravaged region of fotara
this jolly and generous gift giver has
been spotted
on every continent on earth
pierre noel grandfather frost
viejo pasero danchi lauren
though the names are different the
species
is the same but where did the santa
claus
come from over 500 million years ago
the major animal groups begin to appear
in the fossil record
it is during this cambrian period that
the first evidence of a santa can be
seen
initially what we thought we'd found was
just another trilobite but on closer
inspection we came to the conclusion
that
this particular trilobite had a sack of
some type over
what would be its shoulder and fossils
through the ordovician
period and the silurian periods further
support the theory
that during the devonian period the
santas
left the seas to take their first
breaths on land
[Music]
once on land the santa quickly adapted
i'd say about 325 million years ago
during its reptilian
phase was when it began developing its
trademark
ho-ho-ho
now there were no chimneys during the
cretaceous period yet it is during that
time that
the santas began the behavior of
actually trying to jump
down what would be a chimney
but it wasn't until the pliocene epoch
of the neozoic era that we can truly
begin to chart the evolution of
salmon
[Music]
and from its initial discovery in 278
a.d
the santa has continued to evolve
will they thrive in this modern era
tune in tomorrow for more of santa
explore how global warming and in
particular
the melting of the polar ice caps are
bringing about
disturbing warning signs that the
habitat
of the santa and indeed the sanders
themselves
are in jeopardy
buddy we'll take a break when we come
back the whole crowd got bumped out when
they saw it drowned santa
we'll be right back pat oswalt's here